RNA-Seq data are used to study which genes in an
organism are expressed under different conditions.
RNA-Seq data also provide an estimate of relative
gene expression levels within a single sample.
However, when RNA-Seq data are initially obtained,
the data are simply a collection of sequence
information with no genomic context. We do not
know which genes are expressed and at what levels.
In this video, we will discuss the computational
approaches that enable RNA-Seq data to be
efficiently mapped to an organism's genome
assembly. In order to produce RNA-seq data, we
need to first obtain and sequence the RNA from the
organism we are studying. RNA can be extracted from
an organism at specific developmental stages from
specific tissues or after different treatments.
The extracted RNAs undergo library preparation
and are most often sequenced using the Illumina
sequencing technology. We call the sequence data
obtained from sequencing a fragment of RNA a "read".
In general, reads produced by the Illumina
sequencers are between 75 and 150 bases long.
The resulting RNA-Seq data allow us to identify
genes that are expressed and to identify genes
that show changes in expression levels under
different conditions. After the sequence data
have been obtained, we need to map the RNA-Seq
reads to the genome so that we can determine
the genes that are being expressed. This is a
difficult computational problem. The sizes of the
genome assembly for eukaryotes can range from
tens of millions to tens of billions of bases,
and the Illumina sequencer can produce
hundreds of millions of RNA-Seq reads.
In addition, because of sequencing errors and
polymorphisms, we need to allow for a small number
of differences between the RNA-Seq reads and the
genome assembly. If we were to use an algorithm
like BLAST to perform this search, the process
would be extremely slow because the amount of
time required to search each RNA-Seq read would
be proportional to the length of the database.
Hence, we must use an alternative approach that
reduces the amount of time required to search for
sequence similarity between each RNA read and the
genome assembly. This alternative approach takes
advantage of a data structure in computer science
known as a suffix tree. The suffix tree creates an
index of the genome assembly, thereby allowing us
to quickly find the locations where the RNA-seq
read matches the genome assembly. We will use a
simple example to illustrate how to construct a
suffix tree. Our database consists of a sequence of
DNA with 10 nucleotides. We will first specify the
position of each base in the sequence starting
from position 0. The dollar sign at position 10
denotes the end of the sequence. To help us
construct a suffix tree, we will first create
a suffix array. Each element in the suffix array
corresponds to a position in the DNA sequence and
its corresponding suffix. For example, at position
10, the suffix is the dollar sign. At position 9,
the suffix is an "a" followed by the dollar sign.
The suffix "ga$" is at position 8.
The suffix "aga$" is at position
7 and so on. We can continue to build this
list backwards until we reach position 0, where the
suffix is the entire DNA sequence in the database.
We then sort these suffixes alphabetically while
also keeping track of the position of each suffix.
We can convert a suffix array into a suffix
tree by merging the common suffixes in the
list of sorted suffixes. We will examine each
column of the suffix array and create a separate
branch for each unique nucleotide. For example,
in the first column of the suffix array we have
the nucleotides "a," "c," and "g." Hence, we will create
three branches in the first level of the tree.
For the subset of suffixes that begin with an
"a," the second column consists of the dollar sign,
"c," and "g." This means we will create three
branches at the second level of the tree.
When we reach the dollar sign, we will record
the position in the leaf of the tree. In this
case, we will record the position 9 for the
suffix "a$." We can repeat this process
to construct the rest of the subtree
for the suffixes that begin with an "a."
Similarly, we can repeat this process to construct
the subtrees for the suffixes that begin with a
"c" or a "g." After we have created the suffix tree, it
now becomes much easier to find all the matches to
a read in the database. For example, if we want to
find the sequence "cag" in our database we simply
follow the branches of the tree until we match the
entire read and report the positions in the leaves:
in this case, positions 1 and 6. The amount of
time required to find all matches to a read
is proportional to the logarithm of the length
of the read and does not depend on the size of
the database. We can modify the search algorithm to
allow inexact matches. To allow base substitutions,
we can follow multiple paths but charge a penalty
for each mismatch. We can terminate the search
within a subtree once the number of mismatches
exceeds the maximum number of differences allowed.
To facilitate inexact matches with insertions
and deletions, we can use dynamic programming or
a heuristic search to compute the edit distance
of the read against many paths in the suffix tree.